know your angle you have to know you
know the lighting is everything
kim kardashian might be the queen of the
sexy selfie
but there's a new pic of kim going viral
and it has
kim crying it's not funny get out if
you're gonna continue to laugh and make
fun of me crying
laughing that is yes it was a lot of fun
it all started when the keeping up with
the kardashians star's hair stylist
chris appleton shared this pic of kim
sleeping with her mouth
wide open while getting her hair done
the caption
i love you kim i love that kim
quickly commented with lots of laughing
emojis
writing quote i [ __ ] hate you lol
you exhausted me paris hilton weighed in
in the comments writing
sleeping beauty well makeup artist mary
phillips wrote what we're literally all
thinking
quote she's even perfect sleeping with
her mouth open
naturally it didn't take long for that
snap to
go viral you just gotta roll with it
yeah and fans
are loving it so much so that they
started
changing their profile pics to that
photo the 40 year old skims founder
caught on to the social media trend
making note of the lol moment on twitter
writing quote
omg everyone's profile pics i'm crying
it's been a lot of fun listen kim is
booked and busy so we don't blame her
for sneaking in a little nap
like that's not stuff we put on social
media kim has kept it light on social
media since news of her divorce from
husband kanye west was announced
the documents were filed on february
22nd with kim citing
differences as the reason for their
split a source previously told et
that there is no drama between kim and
kanye while another source noted
that their divorce has been a long time
coming
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
you